[Music]
welcome to large-scale multiplayer
gaming with open source my name is mark
module I am a developer advocate for
Google cloud for games and we're here to
talk about some multiplayer game stuff
does that sound like fun yeah awesome
wow you really are excited this is
fantastic
alright great so before we get started I
would love to know a bit more about all
of you just so I can get a sense of who
you all are and what you all do and we
can tailor the content a little bit so
how many people here work in the games
industry a good number of you excellent
awesome
how many of you work on multiplayer
games cool how many of you want to work
in multiplayer games some of you how
many people were just like games are
cool this sounds like fun
that's fine too that's cool alright so
we'll cover seven foundational stuff I'm
will cover us and we'll get deeper into
some projects and we'll talk about some
interesting and fun things so before we
get started though I want to put some
constraints on things a little bit when
we say the woods multiplayer games that
can be a very broad and distributed set
of games outside in the world so when I
bring that in a little so the types of
multiplayer games that I want to talk
about today are your very fast-paced
online competitive multiplayer games so
we're talking your ever watches your
fortnight's your apex legends your
rocket leagues those kinds of really
fast-paced latency-sensitive
online real time multiplayer games those
are the types of games I want to talk
about because they have some
particularly unique constraints and have
some particular unique problems that
they need to have solved to work in a
reliable fashion so we're gonna actually
see this demo today I actually use a FPS
cold
sonarak anyone here know stenotic couple
people awesome it's an open-source fps
if anyone played like Unreal Tournament
2004 an eater it's from there you're
probably quite familiar with how it
works it has captured the flag it has a
lot of the classic modes all that kind
of stuff and we'll have a look at that
later but that's very much the vein of
the type of multiplayer games that I
want to be talking about today
so traditionally how do these kind of
games work there are several models for
how to do this but I want to talk about
one very particular one commonly
referred to as dedicated game servers
because it has become one of the most
prevalent patterns that is used in
especially triple-a large-scale
multiplayer games so what does this look
like so you might have say a couple of
players who are like hey I would like to
play a game so cool they take their game
clients and they usually connect to some
kind of matchmaking system so this
matchmaking systems job is to
potentially take maybe hundreds of
thousands of players take them all in
and say okay let's look at things like
maybe their skill rating maybe their
social graph maybe other aspects of
their gameplay experience and route them
together into a single gameplay like
group that's gonna be a good experience
right like boopie with people who are
like wise in my skill level so it's not
an unbalanced matched or if there are
particular friends that I like playing
with a lot put them together because
that's a really fun experience for me
and so this is a really interesting
problem because you do have to process
potentially thousands and hundreds of
thousands of players at once but the
idea being that yeah we let's get a good
gameplay experience happening between
the players that we have available that
are online and waiting to play again so
once we've solved that hard problem cool
we've grouped together our game our
players we've got a group we then need
to create a dedicated game server for
them to play on so this could be a whole
talking tour of itself but essentially a
dedicated game server is a full
simulation of what happens inside your
game like where your players are what
they're doing it's a Florida if it tells
everything what it is that needs to do
so once we have our players together we
need to talk to some sort of dedicated
game server manager system and this
systems job is potentially to talk to
thousands upon thousands of machines
that are distributed around the world
right because we need to have these
machines close to our players because
latency matters matters a lot so we're
gonna talk to a thousands of machines
around the world and basically be like
okay we need to spin up one of these
dedicated game server person
and therefore like which one has memory
which one has enough CPU what's his
latency metrics compared to where my
players are etc spin it up and then turn
around to be like cool it's spun up now
we need an IP import where is this thing
located so we have an IP import for this
dedicated game server send all that
information way back up the pipe to
those two players that are wanting to
play a game and then they can make a
direct connection to that game server by
the IP import so they can interact
directly with that in memory simulation
as that player plays the game so it's a
lot of work usually speaking or water
this is bespoke most companies generally
do this themselves it's probably less
than ideal so the things I were talking
about today is very much what if there
was what if there was some sort of open
source standard for matchmaking wherein
you don't have to solve some of the hard
problems around how do i process
hundreds of thousands of players
wouldn't that be kind of nice by the
same token wouldn't it be really nice if
there was some sort of open source
standard for game server management
right I don't really care about how to
distribute this workload geographically
and how do i process like orchestrate
these things going up and down I just
want to wrap my game servers so that's
what we're gonna talk about today sound
like fun
good before we get started hands up
people here who know what kubernetes is
a lot of you
fantastic awesome both of the projects
we're gonna talk today are heavily based
on kubernetes but I want to bring it up
for three very important reasons now if
you're not familiar with kubernetes at a
very core level the way I like to
explain it is a system for
programmatically being able to do run
software across lots and lots of
machines everything else on top of that
is really just not sugar but it's open
source and you can run it anywhere and
this is super important because when
latency counts for multiplayer games
being able to put your infrastructure
close to your player base super super
important so the project's I'm we're
talking about today are open source and
they will run on kubernetes and you can
run crouppen Eddie's wherever it is you
need to so that means then if you want
to run it on us like gke awesome love it
great but if you have
coverage like maybe in particular areas
of the world where you just happen to
have a player base we don't cover so
well you can run it there on your own
hardware on another cloud that's really
really important by the same token you
want to run it in your own QA centers
you want to run out on your own machines
you can totally do that as well
secondly this is also really important
standing on the shoulders of giants
obviously many of you familiar
kubernetes has a huge number of
developers working on it and a massive
ecosystem surrounding it so we can take
advantage of all those tools as well
finally simplicity is really important
too usually I talk to a lot of customers
and usually when I talk to customers
they have one system for like their
account management and their marketplace
in the inventory and their player
systems and then when it comes to
multiplayer or dedicated game servers
they have a completely different system
if we can solidify on like one base
platform for all our systems across the
board that's a lot less ops knowledge a
lot less difference in tooling really we
can really just not have to contextually
switch as we operate from one platform
to another cool kubernetes gets me very
excited fantastic so let's get stuck
into the template projects we want to
talk about so we're talking about
matchmaking
open matches a project that came out I
want to say similar between six to eight
months ago it's an open source
matchmaking framework and I want to
emphasize the term framework here it is
built with flexibility scalability and
extensibility what does that mean
basically we want to solve the hard
problems for matchmaking but still allow
you to provide your custom match logic
in the way that makes sense for your
game and your players so horizontal
scalability that stuff shouldn't be a
problem for you really just focusing on
exactly the gameplay experience you want
that's the thing we care about so we're
very flexible we allow you to provide
attributes for your players as they come
in and out basically arbitrarily as you
need and custom match functions
essentially if you can put it inside a
Duggar container you can write a match
function so we don't restrict you in any
way in terms of what language you want
to write it in what platform you write
it in as long as you can put it inside a
container you are good to go
and the big the big thing I think that
gets me most excited about open match is
really the way it works concurrently
what we've seen traditionally in
matchmakers quite often they hit certain
scaling limits and that was a problem we
very much wanted to solve and I'll show
a demo went a little bit about this but
really what we want to be able to solve
those hard problems I was like I had a
hundred thousand players coming in how
do I concurrently process match
functions over these things we want to
solve those problems for you and leave
that kind of problem the more the more
game specific stuff to yourselves so
we'll have a look at that so
doo-doo-doo-doo we can switch over to my
demo screen please wonderful thank you
so much all right so I have an empty
crib minetti's cluster as you can see
it's not entirely empty I do have there
we go if I get counting maps I do have
the configuration for our 'print match
already installed it's just the standard
config map that you get with the example
but we're debugging turned off and I'm
gonna scroll up and match so those not
familiar example sorry we're just gonna
install some yellow files so I'm gonna
open man chooses Redis for a specific
datastore you can either use one in
cluster which we're gonna do here or you
could also use something like memory
store or any other manage Redis
beautiful and that's gonna install a
bunch of stuff alright and that's really
it there's nothing much more else to it
there's a bunch of components inside
open match that are configurable and we
can mix and match a few things I'm not
going to talk too much about today but
those exist now I'm gonna copy paste
here because these are big commands and
we're gonna put some we're gonna add
some players inside ARP and match so
what we're gonna do here is basically
put in seven cycles of 10,000 game
players so 10,000 generated players for
us take a little second for it to come
up come on run so we're gonna spin up
seven 17,000 players and insert those
inside inside our Open match cluster
you know you want to work the demagogues
apparently love me today come on you can
do it I believe in you we go there we go
took a second here we go
wonderful okay so this is generating
10,000 players will see a few numbers of
these there we go so there we go
beautiful
obviously it hadn't downloaded the image
for a while so that was taking a little
second so that's now generating some
players right so 70,000 not a bad number
here we go here we go here we go so
while it's doing that I'm gonna grab the
next command so what we're gonna do is
we're actually going to run some some
matchmaking once this is done so you can
actually see the concurrency in action
alright so we have 70,000 players
beautiful all right give me a bash
lovely and I'm gonna steal this command
because I can never remember how it goes
wonderful so what I do is that takes a
second to come up sometimes and they run
that again there we go
that Ram really quickly so what we're
gonna what we did there is we ran let me
scroll up we ran and matchmaking
function just a really simple
matchmaking function that we use inside
we having signed the example and we ran
it with the concurrency of - I just
can't see - and what we're actually
doing is we're looking for groups of 16
players and so it's gonna run through
its it's splitting that up essentially
really not the best wrapping there but
you can see that there we're splitting
it up into teams of 16 and then we have
like it splits it up into four poles
each of about 14,000 players and
unsurprisingly this is pretty successful
trying to find groups of 16 inside
14,000 we have quite a few to choose
from we can get you know we have a
number of successes for 64 players
matched and we have a third point of
about 26 players per second which is not
a lot but we can do better
so let's actually do the same thing but
let's bump that number up to within
currency of 20 so this usually takes 20
seconds you'll start to see here it'll
say insufficient players that's because
some of our players pool sizes are less
than 16 and
in some cases and that's fine but it's
gonna break apart all the players that
we have and this is configurable you can
kind of play with how things get broken
apart and then process a much larger
number of players allowing us to get
much better throughput inside of a match
there we go all right beautiful so now
we can see here we've actually matched
about 4,200 players a little better than
the you know 64 odd we had before now we
can get through a throughput of more
like 168 players per second so this is
how we can start to distribute the
workload of what happens inside open
match to be able to get higher
throughput without you know we really
didn't have to change anything inside
our matching function we just changed
their concurrency which we get means we
get some much nicer master three-point
can we go back to slides please awesome
all right so this is a bit better right
we didn't have to write our matchmaker
instead with this custom matchmaker
we've put in open match we use comment
open source things like Redis which many
you're probably familiar with and we're
able to insert Crippen Eddie's and
install open match on top of a creepy
entities cluster as a customer appliance
and we're good to go
but that's great we can still do the
same thing we had before where we have
players connecting to dedicated game
servers why whoops
I want that sign there we go but we
still have this server manager yeah we
still have this bespoke thing that it
would be really nice if I didn't have to
build quite honestly so this is where we
get into a glass so a ghana's is another
open-source project it's built in
collaboration with Ubisoft and it is an
open-source project for hosting scaling
and orchestrating dedicated game servers
on top of kubernetes I'm sure that
wasn't surprising at this point I'm sure
many of you were seeing that coming
it's been a really great collaboration
between us a newbie so I just want to
highlight it they've been able to bring
their their institutional knowledge
about how to run dedicated game servers
and large multiplayer games over to us
and we've been able to bring our
knowledge of kubernetes and open source
and it's just been really lovely I have
to be completely honest with you so
super delighted to be working with
them on this so let's look at how
organize works very similarly right do
you have a dedicated game server and you
can put it inside a container you are
pretty much good to go I assume we're
all fairly familiar with docker
containers that's something we're all
familiar awesome there is a dedicated
SDK that needs to be integrated in some
way shape or form that a CKD tells us
things like hey this game servers ready
whether it's healthy or not access to
configuration things like that but this
is pretty easy to do it's not an onerous
task we already support a variety of
languages including C++ and node and
rust but it is old G RPC and or
rest-based so the short answer is if you
have a game server in any language we
can support it you'll be fine actually
the Unreal sdk will be coming out this
afternoon once I put the release
candidate out so that'll be nice too we
have more stuff coming yeah so has some
people here who have written cribben
adizero files many of you cool if you
haven't that's fine it's like one of the
declarative ways that you can tell
things to-- kubernetes to do stuff
anything you see here on a llam file
you can also do it directly through the
crouppen Eddie's API as well so once you
install a gun is what it actually is
doing is extending kubernetes itself to
provide it new nouns basically new
actions that it knows how to do things
with natively this is like one of the
really cool things about kubernetes and
standing of the shoulder of giants that
gets me very very excited so once you
restore lagunes it understands what a
game server is and it under standards
and it understands game server life
cycles and this is really important
because game servers are kind of special
in that when you don't have players on
game servers and you spin them up if you
delete game servers that don't have
players on them nobody seems to mind but
when you delete game servers that do
have plays on them players seem to mind
a lot they get their games shut down in
the middle of their gameplay experience
they're not happy they push things on
reddit they tend to write things steam
reviews it's just bad for everyone so
once we have this installed suddenly a
gun is really does understand
oh they're players on here we'll have a
look at that a little bit later as well
so here we define a game server we can
give it a name a referenceable name or
even have it create one for us we can
specify the port policies we want to
have ago nays will manage dynamic port
allocations so we can do that direct
connection we saw earlier and then
finally we specified the container that
we want how game server today
for those of you who are more familiar
with cribben eddie's you can run a full
pod spec here as well
so if you want to run multiple
containers or volume mounts or config
maps or any of that cool stuff we
totally can but we can do better than
just individual game servers as well we
can do fleets of game servers so
traditionally speaking well you probably
want to do with your game servers is
spin them up and have a warm set ready
to go waiting for players to come in
game servers can take a little while to
spin up so you want to have that that
there's those sitting there ready to go
so if people are familiar with pods and
deployments very similar we have game
servers and fleets so fleets are just
lots of game servers we specify how many
replicas we want and then we specify a
game server specification and it's the
job of the fleet to ensure that we have
lots of these ready to go that's really
it if one of them falls over or maybe
one of them ends we make sure we have
another one spun up and it keeps them
alive and healthy so here we have the
sinaitic game server here and we have
two replicas of it available now this is
the fun thing and I think again
something particular to game servers
themselves
we don't have load balancers right so
how do we get players to a game server
and mock it as hey players are playing
on this thing so we have this concept of
what we call allocation so here I show
what is the ammo file you'll probably do
it if you were implementing it
programmatically through the kubernetes
api but i say to the gate i say to creep
it sorry i say to a gun is hey i would
like to create me an allocation please
grab me a game server in this particular
instance out of the stenotic fleet and
market is allocated and do it for me
atomically and do it for me safe
all right that's an interesting and fun
problem right like other things could be
happening to your servers they could be
coming up and down but it gonna solves
that sort of infrastructure problem of
saying oh yeah you've got like 10,000
game servers running in this cluster
awesome here's one that's safe right and
it's now mocked is allocated and so we
know there are players on it so why
don't I show you that in action could
that be kind of fun sweet all right can
we switch back over to demo we already
have oh you're all amazing so first
thing I'm gonna do is a stroll agon is
I'm gonna use helm Helms a package
manager for kubernetes so if you've ever
use anything like yeah more apt or
homebrew very much in that vein so I'm
just gonna install what Bonnie's ago on
is I like how I'm Helms great so it's
gonna take the helm chart it's gonna
install it boom there we go it was
literally that easy which is lovely I
can actually show you get pods namespace
we can now see that we have several
components already just sitting there
these are these are just the pots of a
bonus we actually really don't care
about them too much
so let's write let's run let's run a
stenotic fleet like we just saw earlier
right so I can apply - F examples some
not ache okay cool
so this creates a fleet you know what's
really cool about extending kubernetes
as well is all the extensions go through
the API all the way down to the tooling
so I can now say get fleets and if you
show me fleets and will see things like
oh cool we have two desired awesome so
we had before and two of them are ready
we can also look at them slightly
differently we can also say get game
server right we can see we have two that
are available and ready to go as well
that's awesome but to game servers
boring let's get more let's scale our
fleet
I also don't know if you noticed but I
get tab-completion on here too
I love this say like 200 games service
that's way more fun right
much better number and we can look at
this in a couple of different ways so
here we have a fleet right we currently
have 200 they're gonna start coming up
to becoming ready
they spin up really quick there we go 57
looking great lovely if we come across
to here you can actually also start to
see some of the metrics that we have
available to us as well this usually
runs a little bit behind because it
pulls every 30 seconds it'll pick up in
a sec but we can start seeing things
like rates 5 how many game servers we
have what state they're in count per
type so all those sort of metrics that
you need as well for running game
servers at scale come bundled in with a
ganas similarly you have similar things
in open match but these are the sort of
things that you shouldn't have to care
about as a game developer this should
just be stuff that you all need how many
game servers you're running is a
standard metric we should all just have
this shouldn't be stuff that you have to
build yourself so we can see all sorts
it up and this is just one dashboard out
of many dashboards that we have inside
Ghana's so we have a look over here ok
so this is actually the the dashboards
running is slightly behind but we can
see we have 200 ready that's amazing
so let's uh let's allocate let's do that
that'll be fun
- F examples it's not a game server
allocation so I would probably normally
do this through an API like I keep
saying I'm gonna do it through the ammo
file because that's what we're used to
using here and I'm just gonna write - oh
yeah moles so we can see the response
when it finally finishes so boom okay so
that's given us an allocated game server
there's a bunch of stuff up top the bit
I really care about here is this write
state allocated we have an IP we have a
port we have a game server that's been
given to us that's essentially
sacrosanct so let's play game so it
sound like fun yeah this is this is the
fun bit all right
let's plug it let's see if I can type
really small things in front of it live
audience
41 7 8 8 9 join beautiful black screen
is actually good alright so this is
going to connect to the game server that
we basically like we spent up to hundred
of these entire entire cluster then we
allocated it and it looked into the
cluster and was like hey let's let's
spin up one of these and then there we
go I'm gonna play on my trackpad this is
me playing sonarak on a cluster that's
running us east or us west one or
another there are some players around
here somewhere
without fail there we go
as soon as I play in front of a group of
people there's never anyone around oh
the most important part of this whole
talk really all right cool that was fun
but I actually want to show you some
other fun stuff off to um so I'm gonna
do let's do a couple more allocations
because I want to show up this is this
cool so we have we can see here that we
have three game servers that are
allocated right we essentially have
three people three game servers that
have people playing on it so let's scale
this down we're like actually these game
servers we don't like it there's
something wrong with it something like
that so let's just say replica 0 like
flip the table and just be like we hate
this thing now so that's gonna start
scaling that down but we're always gonna
see that those three allocated servers
always stay there this is what like
organized does a whole bunch of stuff
but this I think it's like one of the
core basic things that it understands is
that while we might have a variety of
these being shut down we don't touch
allocated game servers super super
important we don't interrupt player
playing a game don't ever do it it's bad
bad bad bad bad bad
so lots and lots of fun so that's yeah
so if we actually run that again there
we are so we still always will see those
allocated game servers until the players
finish playing their games and those
game servers self shutdown very
important stuff cool we go back to
slides please excellent wonderful okay
so things are always better with friends
so let's see if we can make this work
together so we do have stuff wherein we
can make these talk to each other so
what we can do is we can install
basically what we commonly refer to as a
director or basically blue code between
open match and a game server scalar
which can be custom if you so desire so
that a matchmaker can take the things in
open match right you run your custom
match logic there it can talk to our
ganas and be like hey I've got players
let's um action I can make a game and
then that game server can be marked as
allocated those players can then play
that game and continue on and have a
really good time so one slide went back
to demo fund so in in cooking show
parlance here's one I prepared earlier
so I already have that's you know what I
want is all I already have open match
installed I have a gun is installed
there's a bunch of stuff already in this
cluster but what we're going to do is
we're going to create that fleet like we
saw previously
so that's gonna create a fleet for us of
a really simple game server it literally
just takes a UDP packet with some text
in it and it spits out a log that's like
I know stenotic is like super exciting
but this is like just very simple for
demonstrative purposes and then what
we're also gonna do is we're gonna
install the director basically this is
the glue code that says hey this is how
I want open match to talk to organize to
scale to allocate game servers for me
basically in the way that makes sense
for me so cool that's that's good to go
lovely I'm gonna grab this from down
here because it's also got oh yes there
we go beautiful then I'm gonna write a
little a little script here and I'm
gonna make sure this is ready beautiful
this is gonna do a couple of things so
we're gonna work on a much smaller scale
this time we're just gonna work with one
player just so we can see the flow all
the way through so here this is just
gonna generate one player for us very
simple right nothing too complicated but
then we're gonna spin up a once we've
got one player ever matching this
instance is gonna be like oh we only
view one player for a game so cool we
can match make them we're gonna hit
enter and it's gonna go cool we have a
player awesome
we're gonna go and telegin is hey
allocate me a game server so this here
IP import of the game server that just
got allocated to us from a goddess
awesome next this little script is going
to spin up a client lovely so this is a
little client we can use it to send UDP
messages to the allocated game server so
why don't we actually pop over to our
other tab we have a look at our game
servers you see we have one that's it
true that's allocated that's fun let me
see which one is going on there seven
six one six I just want to get the logs
from the right one
it's may have been lying around for
divorce it keeps the Geo logs simply D
be beautiful alright so we can see that
that's running now let's send a little
command we'll say now I want you to
ignore the error a bit at the bottom
because demos always fail the day before
but the business that I care about is
where it says hello right so I've got
connectivity now right like I
essentially can play this game I can
send packets to it in theory it should
be able to send them back but we'll
ignore that for now but we can we can
work that all the way through so
essentially we've we've been able to do
the full stack from going from
matchmaking all the way through to
allocation of game server and having a
person play the game now we can quit
this and see something else that's also
kind of cool so what's gonna happen now
is this little script is gonna start
just allocating game servers it's
basically gonna keep adding players to
the matchmaking queue as it keeps doing
that it's gonna keep going to Ivana's
and saying hey can I have a game server
now one thing we haven't talked a bit
about today is the auto scaling
capabilities of Ivana's so here we have
one of our our fleet auto scalars
already set up for us and we can see
that as we add players our allocated
game servers goes back up to 6 the order
scalar is starting to kick off right
we've got this at a really low number so
you can see the numbers go really slowly
otherwise it zooms up really fast but
you can start to see the numbers start
to rise as we have this up to say hey
can we have two ready game servers at
any point in time and so every 30
seconds it's gonna kick over and say
okay cool there we go let's add in
number two and then we'll add some more
matchmaking to it and then we'll just
keep on rotating through so we have some
nice some nice functionality there for
auto scaling as well which is super cool
awesome can I go back to slides please
excellent
all right so what does this mean so like
just like wrap this up with nice visual
diagrams so we've had the players they
want to play a game and in this instance
now they're gonna talk to open match
alright we're gonna have our custom
match logic in there
right we're gonna distribute that player
load over a lots and lots of machines
right we can do that for you which is
lovely and you just want about your
custom match logic from there open match
can't talk directly through the
kubernetes api right usually through a
director or something similar that's
hooked into open match to tell it how we
want it to allocate game servers through
a ganas a ganas itself can then look at
a fleet of game servers that are already
pre warmed and ready to go pull one out
atomically and be like alright this one
here that's allocated and hand that
information all the way back up to the
players who want to play again then
finally those players can connect
directly to that game server as we saw
here and as we saw with the synodic demo
and continue to play that game we didn't
have to build a lot of bespoke stuff we
can work on an open standard which means
you can run anywhere we can really just
kind of stand on the shoulders of giants
ourselves as game developers and take
advantage of the tools that already
exist and really focus on the gameplay
state and the gameplay mechanics and
those aspects that really matter inside
our game so there's a bunch more to both
of these projects that we don't have
time to talk about today I know I've
mentioned it a bunch but I want to
hammer home anyway about working on
cloud providers it works across all
cloud providers basically all these
projects work on vanilla kubernetes
there's nothing special in any of those
both projects have auto scaling
capabilities we saw some of that inside
of ganas there's some more as well ganas
works with the krupa IDs autoscaler open
match has similar auto scaling
capabilities as well both projects have
local development tools so if you don't
want to split up an entire crew Binet DS
cluster locally you're able to use some
lightweight tooling to be able to access
and interrupt Ouiser and develop with
both of those projects as well and as we
saw briefly as well both projects have
metrics and dashboards right metrics and
is really important for those day three
day four operations so we want to make
sure that the standard metrics that you
all need to do those kind of roles come
along with both of these projects as
well on top of that both of these
projects have pretty solid roadmaps agon
is is still technically alpha
we are slated to go 1.0 at some point
this year yes that is a broad statement
I'm very happy with broad statements
you'll see a lot of things coming more
performance improvements we've already
done a whole bunch of performance work
and we've made it drastically more
important form more performant than it
was before more metrics as well we want
to do more commercial engines as I said
I'm reels coming Welding the release
candidate today we're working on unity
soon it's already on the one point our
roadmap how it's just sort out multi
cluster is also in front of mind you're
probably going to want to run multiple
little clusters around the world so how
you do multi cluster orchestration and
like multi cluster allocation is already
in the works and you can see some work
in the current release candidate for
that as well also Windows hosting
minigame developers use Windows machines
people want Windows hosting thankfully
in group entities 1.14 the ga support
for Windows is there
we're just waiting that to trickle down
into cloud providers as well so lots of
good stuff in that on top of that open
match also has a quite a quite good
roadmap coming up they want to look at a
long live matching logic so for example
if you just want to have a service
that's running up and you consistently
hit that so that you can consistently
hit that end point to run your custom
match logic more metrics and dashboards
they're player and match tracing is a
big thing again so you can trace what is
happening with each individual player as
they go through your system when they
also want to look to increase and
develop their build change for
development tooling as well I would be
very remiss if I didn't mention it if
you got to try out a ghana's it's
currently running 0.8.1 so it's a couple
of versions behind but if you just want
a simple getting started experience with
a gun is you can go to the google cloud
marketplace now click a couple of
buttons and get a cluster up and running
and you can take it for a spin so it's
super nice finally before we wrap up
everything I definitely want to say both
projects are very alive very active but
we're always looking for more
contributors more people to provide
feedback so if you are interested
definitely get involved on slack come
hang
with us on github file bugs send feature
requests we definitely are looking for a
diverse set of opinions for a wide
variety of people from the games
industry to come help us make these
projects the best they possibly can be
that is the power of open source but
before you run off as well if you have
any questions I'll be around at the
conference if you go over into the demo
area build and scale through Google
cloud you can come talk to us as well
about both of these projects and see a
demonstration as well finally if you
want to follow us on Twitter I'm at
neurotic because I joined Twitter in
2006 and that's something you could do
in 2006 but you can also follow the
iguana's project on AG on a stove but
you can also see organize a tag on a
stove and open match dev for more
information finally thank you so much
for spending the last 40 minutes with me
I know your time is valuable so I really
appreciate it and I hope you all have a
wonderful iron thank you so much
[Music]
you